former CIA director John Brennan is
firing back this morning at President
Trump for pulling his security clearance
Brennan writes in the New York Times
that the president's denial of any
collusion with Russia's quote hogwash in
Brennan's words mr. Trump clearly has
become more desperate to protect himself
and those close to him which is why he
made the politically motivated decision
to revoke my security clearance we show
Jiang is at the White House with more on
this story we should good morning to you
good morning Gail and to everybody the
president's original statement about
this was dated for July 26th 2018 but
not delivered until yesterday and now
critics are accusing him of holding it
until he needed something as a
distraction from other controversies
well Brennan has been a longtime critic
of President Trump who tells The Wall
Street Journal one of the reasons he
revoked Brennan's security clearance was
his role in the Russia investigation the
president has a constitutional
responsibility to protect classified
information and who has access to it
White House press secretary Sarah
Sanders spelled out reasons President
Trump says he stripped former CIA
director John Brennan of his security
clearance mr. Brennan has a history that
calls into question his objectivity and
credibility in an interview with The
Wall Street Journal mr. Trump cited
Brennan as among those he held
responsible for Robert Miller's Russia
investigation I call it the rigged
witch-hunt it is a sham the president
told the paper and these people let it
so I think it's something that had to be
done he added after the announcement
Brennan blamed President Trump for
trying to intimidate and retaliate I've
seen this type of behavior and actions
on the part of foreign tyrants and
despot I never ever thought that I would
see it here in the United States part of
their public feud played out in
president Trump's interview with CBS
Evening News anchor Jeff Glor I have no
confidence in a guy like Brennan I think
he's a total lowlife of the others the
president is threatening with the loss
of their security clearances eight are
former US officials who have all
to sized him publicly and one current
Justice Department lawyer who had
contact with the former British spy
claiming to have dirt on the president
the Office of the Director of National
Intelligence issued a statement saying
president Trump has the ultimate
authority to decide who holds a security
clearance
John we J thanks